when i found out you could go on the
cia's website when i was much younger
and more paranoid i'm like i'm not going
there i'll get on a list you will but
it's like what do you think the cia is
like
oh [ __ ] this this comic on our website
yeah call call out the black helicopters
but comic with a large platform oh yes
yeah right a comic with a large platform
you can you can use them to control to
control to get inside to get inside to
get close to the other comics the other
comics the large part to get close to
joe rogan oh yeah and start yeah and
start to manipulate the public yeah
right right you know honestly like
you kind of like that was that's like a
fun fantasy to think about like how
[ __ ] cool would that be for like the
men in black to come to you and be like
listen
i need you to infiltrate the [ __ ]
comedy scene
you gotta you gotta help them write
better jokes i'm like i don't write
great jokes but like the
you you found the wrong guy but like
you're really playing the long game on
this one because i think you've been
on um you've been doing your podcast for
a long time you've been on joe rogan's
podcast like over 50 times and have not
yet initiated the phase two of the
operation where you try to manipulate
his mind
well no the game joe and i play from
time to time on the podcast
and like and i i honestly like at some
point i'm like joe i just did the same
thing you did to me to joe i'm like
don't you think they can get you don't
you think at some point
we we are blazed i don't mean it i don't
think i don't think joe's like it wasn't
like i'm really thinking like man
they're gonna take him into some room
and be like joe we need you to do this
or that but because i said that now
people like ah duncan called it you know
what i mean and it's like
you know what i mean and and though the
reason they're saying well he called it
is just because joe has a super popular
podcast and people like
when you have a super popular podcast
some percentage of people
watching the podcast are going to be you
know believe things like that they're
going to have a paranoid cognitive bias
that makes them think anybody who is in
the public has been what's the word for
compromised compromised by the state
look i'll fan the flames of what you
just said
i went on the cia's website and i
realized that you could
apply for a job on the cia's website
which i found to be hilarious so i'm
like all right what happens if i apply
for a job in the cia now
even then i was not like such an idiot
that
i would want a job at the cia
not just for like ethical considerations
but
i think the skip probably the scariest
part about the cia is like you're just
at a cubicle and you're like having to
deal with maps and like just you know
what i mean just stop dying lots of
paperwork paperwork it sucks i bet their
cafeteria has shitty food anyone in the
cia listening can you confirm that about
the food they're not going to be able to
tell you what the food is like
organization no they might it might be
awesome but we won't know about it okay
we're in vegas yeah and
you can bat
food at the cia cafeteria is good
food at the ca cafeterias sucks
what are you bet not
so let's let's like uh cleanse the
palette what's good it's like you know
silicon valley companies google and so
on that's good when i went to netflix
their cafeteria looked like a medieval
feast like they had pigs with apples in
their mouth and giant bowls of skittles
probably like vegan pigs yeah
no those are i'm pretty oh i didn't know
i didn't get close enough i was like i
think that was a pig
okay
this is literally a pig
um yeah
yeah you're right you're right i
probably would not bet much money on cia
food being any good right it's it's
gotta suck it's like shitty like pasta
probably like hospital food is like
maybe a little better than when you go
to the hospital cafeteria but anyway
folks at the cia please send me evidence
uh or any other intelligence agencies if
you would like to recruit some evidence
of better food yes sin lex can you
please send likes pictures of the cia
cafeteria and if you accidentally send
them pictures of the aliens or the alien
technology you have that we won't tell
anybody yeah but the the uh you tried to
apply do you even have a resume no then
i would never [ __ ] hire me ever but
like i applied for the job and uh just
out of curiosity what happens and then
at the end
of the application when you hit enter it
says
well first it says don't tell anyone you
apply for the cia so i'm already out but
the second thing it says is
you don't need to reach out to us we'll
come to you yeah which is really when
you're like it's late at night and
you're being an [ __ ] and applied to
work at the cia it's kind of the last
thing you want to hear
you know you know i don't want to be
secretly approached by some intelligence
officer now anyone who talks to you you
think is a cia's saying remember that
time you applied oh god yeah yeah
sometimes i'm like oh [ __ ] are you one
of them
you